foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
as you can see we have placed another
hold on the t-clock at T minus 24
minutes we do need additional time for
propellant conditioning we're going to
stand by for additional updates and I'll
send that to you as soon as I have them
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
ly holding the clock and taking it back
once more we just coordinated for a new
t0 time with the range our new t0 time
is now 14 40 Eastern that is 2 40 p.m
Eastern we're going to allow a little
bit more time for propellant
conditioning as some of you may know
this is not at all unusual for a first
launch this is perfectly expected since
we want
all systems to be as perfect as possible
before we do this
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
if you're just joining us we are now
back at T minus 38 minutes we did set
back the clock and coordinated with the
range for a new t0 time of 1440 Eastern
that is 2 40 PM Eastern we did add this
time to allow us to continue our
propellant conditioning we'll continue
to provide you updates as we get them
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
yesterday
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
if you're just joining us we are
currently at T minus 23 minutes if you
recall we did set the t-clock back a
little bit in order to allow for
propellant conditioning you might also
be able to see that the clouds are
coming in our team is keeping a close
eye on the weather right now just
because we want the maximum visibility
that we can get for this historic first
launch we'll keep you updated along the
way
[Music]
thank you
we're going to stand by for a
situational briefing from the launch
director Clay Walker in Mission Control
let's listen in for the next few minutes
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
now that we're expecting the go no-go
polls to occur in approximately three
minutes while we wait let's talk about
the nose cone that we have today
so we don't have a customer payload on
board but we do have a Memento inside of
our nose cone we have included our first
ever 3D printed piece from our Stargate
printer and of course it was a failed
print since no one had ever done it
before
as you see on your screen that is our
nose cone Memento that piece is six and
a half inches in diameter and weighs
about three pounds it is our first
completed circular test article for
which we used our first generation
aluminum alloy since then we've added a
machined centerpiece with a glhf good
luck have fun and our mitosis logo to
commemorate this Maiden launch
from our very first failed print seven
years ago relativity's team relentlessly
overcame thousands of challenges Against
All Odds to get to today our first 3D
printed rocket launch like the first
print Taran one is the first step of
many towards making Humanity a
multi-planetary species
as a reminder our primary objective for
today is to gather as much data as
possible to help develop our future
Vehicles including taranar our larger
medium to heavy lift reusable launch
vehicle in just a few minutes the launch
director is going to pull the teams for
launch so let's listen in
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I go FTS FTS go FTS go RF RF go RF
go GNC GNC go GNC go flight software
flight software go lights off or go prop
one prop one go prop one go prop two
prop two go prop two go fluids one lose
one go so it's one go fluids two flutes
two go so it's two go loads loads go
loads go rock
ranges group osm
go Summers go osm let's go RC
RC go vehicle vehicle let's go Vehicles
go ce's go C's go LC LC go
all parties have reported go for launch
countdown
once the t-clock begins anyone can call
for a hold at any time if a hold is
called prior to T minus 70 seconds the
t-clock will continue to roll until T
minus 70 seconds at which point a hold
will be automatically initiated a hold
is not possible after T minus 70 seconds
and any hold call after that time will
result in a terminal count aboard
should hold our manual board be
necessary the person calling for a hold
or board should stay clearly on comms
hold hold hold or abort abort abort in
the event that the osm requires a hold
osm will initiate the hold command on
the osm GUI notify LD and the RC on the
primary net
lce on Bravo can we open stage one fuel
please
copy opening stage one fuel blades
gcvc please limit com channels alpha
bravo charlie countdown unless Direct by
LCR LD
support room this is vehicle
you just heard our launch director
complete the go no go polling with our
mission control Team all systems as you
heard are currently healthy so as of now
we're able to proceed with our scheduled
launch time in about 12 minutes
throughout today's live stream you've
been hearing call outs for Mission
Control let's take a moment to introduce
you to our mission control Team Clay
Walker launch director John wiswell
launch conductor James Harris chief
engineer Elijah Escovedo and Zoe dickert
on vehicle controls Brian batters Ground
Control Bill stack ground Joy mazdell
range control
there are a few notable members of
leadership supporting today's launch who
are also here at launch control this
includes our co-founder and CEO Tim
Ellis our chief operating officer who
leads product execution Zach Dunn vice
president of test and launch Don
catterbeck and director of Cape
operations Pat svatek these are among
many many others who are making today's
launch happen
for those of you that are just tuning in
you can see Taryn one on the pad this
rocket is 85 3D printed by mass it is a
hundred and ten feet tall and seven and
a half feet in diameter stage one has
nine aon1 engines and our second stage
has an aeon vacuum engine these engines
are also 3D printed using powder bed
Fusion
we're gonna go ahead and take a moment
to pause and stay tuned as we wait on
the launch countdown
[Music]
we are getting extremely close here our
countdown sequence will begin in T minus
10 minutes so just 30 seconds away
minus 10 minutes countdown sequences
started
we're currently at T minus 9 minutes and
40 seconds in the upcoming minutes
you're going to hear several call outs
from mission control as we go through
the final pre-launch procedural test
including the priming of the igniter's
final engine checkouts transporter
erector retraction and getting that
final go for launch again we're now
pressing the tanks to flight pressures
and we're currently proceeding with our
scheduled launch time
thank you
we'll be looking for a call out in the
next 30 seconds that stage one is
transitioning to helium
pneumatics has transitioned to helium
there you go that means we're
pressurizing the propellant tanks
we'll be charging these stage 2 igniters
to flight Targets in just about 10
seconds
foreign
let's go ahead and walk through the
launch timeline yeah sure at uh T-minus
three minutes the transporter erector
will retract just a few degrees to give
the proper angle for umbilical
separation at this point the vehicle
will be on internal power
at T minus 70 seconds the vehicle will
go into terminal count this is again
when the vehicle's internal flight
computer takes control of the countdown
we then go into final flight termination
checks and get FTS go from the launch
conductor in coordination with the
mission flight control officer and
Operation Safety manager
at T minus six seconds we'll have
ignition of those nine beautiful 3D
printed and one engines so you'll see
the Flames beneath the rocket at that
point and at t0 we will have liftoff
shortly after that at two plus two
seconds the strong back will throw back
to assist in removing the umbilicals and
clear the path for the vehicle to fly
vertical
at t plus 12 seconds we'll begin our
pitch over program and at t plus 80
seconds is that important Milestone of
Max Q or the point of Maximum Dynamic
pressure
again where the structural loads on the
vehicle are the highest making it one of
the more challenging phases of flight
at approximately t plus 160 seconds will
have main engine cutoff or Miko where
the stage one engines will shut off
followed shortly by stage separation and
the Aeon vacuum engine igniting second
stage will burn for a little under five
minutes and then at approximately t plus
463 seconds we'll have second engine cut
off or Seco as a reminder we do not have
a fairing or any payload deployments for
this first launch
with that we'll go ahead and wait and
stay tuned with Mission Control
and once again we are so honored to be
hosting at this launch with you all
today I'm arwa tazani Kelly technical
program manager for test and launch at
relativity space and I'm Rachelle
anaceto chief of staff for the vehicle
architecture and Technology team and we
are now less than five minutes away from
watching the world's first 3D printed
rocket launch
stage one like that is priming in
we're currently priming the igniters
with gaseous oxygen and gaseous hydrogen
our ignition system uses these
propellants flowing across a glow plug
stage two is on internal power
and you just saw the transporter erector
cradle disengage
there we go the Cradle arm slowly
started releasing stage two at the top
there so that the strong back camera
tracked and we confirmed that stage two
is now on internal power
oh
foreign
power
the stage one TVC checkout complete
we just completed stage one TVC
checkouts that means that we performed
the final thrust vector control health
checks on both stages before liftoff
we'll be doing stage two or rather
completing stage two within the next 10
seconds
fh2 TVC checkups
[Music]
next up will be retracting the strong
back and then our range coordinator will
ask the range for their status one last
time
foreign
status
and that was confirmation that the range
is green for launch we are almost a
minute away
announcement on count.net with the LD
we're holding it T-minus 70 seconds
prior to terminal count to address issue
all right you heard Clay Walker our
launch director there we are holding at
T-Mobile back retracting 69 seconds to
address an issue we are however at the
same time retracting our strong back
that black trust structure there is the
strong back it'll retract just a few
degrees to prepare for umbilical
separation
will stand by for further updates from
mission control and we'll update you on
the hold
as a reminder of what our launch
director said earlier this is the last
opportunity that our team can call a
hold so the team chose to take that
option at T minus 70 seconds and ensure
everything is nominal before we go into
our terminal account sequence
again what you're looking at
is 85 3D printed and it is about to fly
those white clouds you see coming out of
the rocket are due to the venting of the
chilled gas from the rocket into the
humid Florida air out here that's why
the gas condenses into vapor and looks
like clouds
I'm hearing that our t-clock will resume
in about one minute
down as well
approximately 20 seconds transitioning
to terminal count
as a reminder from here on out when the
t-clock resumes our countdown sequence
will be automated and controlled by the
internal flight computer
we are extending the hole just a little
bit longer we're going to stand by for
further updates for Mission Control
announcement I'll count down that but
they don't be I'm having terminal
counter forward taking the vehicle in
the 15 recycle options
you heard that announcement from our
launch director we're going to have an
update momentarily as to what happened
with our automated report
foreign
if you're just joining us we did have an
automated abort at T minus 70 seconds
the team is currently assessing if we're
able to recycle since we are still
within our launch window so we'll
provide that update as soon as we have
confirmation for Mission Control
foreign
once again we had an automated aboard at
T minus 70 seconds our launch director
and our teams and Mission Control are
currently assessing the recycle options
that we have for today since we're
currently still within our launch window
we're standing by to hear that update
from Clay Walker
thank you
foreign
difference
all right I just received confirmation
that we are going to recycle and we have
an updated t0 time of 15 55 Eastern so
again that's 15 55 Eastern approximately
45 minutes from now we're gonna keep
going
you provide an update on the cause of
the previous automated abort the stage 2
oxygen temperatures were out of limits
so that's why we had that aboard at T
minus 70 seconds now we're going to
resolve this issue and continue on with
our recycled and new t0 time of 15 55
Eastern
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
quick update here that our updated
launch time that's been confirmed with
the range is at 15 45 Eastern that is 3
45 PM Eastern the T clock at the top of
your screen is accurate and will keep
you up to date as to when we are going
to lift off
friends
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
we are currently at T minus 23 minutes
and 56 seconds we're currently waiting
for an update from Mission Control
let's continue listening in and stand by
thank you
[Music]
foreign
operations for the day
thanks for playing
all right you just heard that update
from Mission Control we are
unfortunately scrubbing at today's
operations we're going to stand by for
additional details from Clay Walker
no no
no
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]